hello kids who shouldn't be watching the
Internet at this hour of the day 9 a.m.
you should be in school right now I
don't know what you're thinking I'm Greg
Alba no i'm john c reilly hey better a
lot better
Wow good good so we're gonna talk about
Ralph breaks the Internet today I'm
excited to talk about this film I'm sure
we're the only ones who have uploaded
this video at 9 a.m. Pacific Standard
Time
except JT 859 859 that's the guy right
there before we hop into this review I
wanted to say thank you to everyone
who's been following us on the Stardust
a bo 300 post officially 7 point 4 K
followers we're trying to get to 7 point
5 it's a lot this is free to download
free to use 30-second reactions for any
film TV show or trailer a lot of them
are awesome micro sketches thank you to
all who have been following us there so
far anywho link in the description box
let's get into this review so if you've
seen the trailer for Ralph breaks the
Internet it's pretty easy to make out
what this films about Penelope and her
game that I keep calling candy cane land
which I know that's not what it's called
sugar rush games getting shut down they
need a part so they the only way to do
it is they got to go into the Internet
in order to retrieve a certain item and
through some stupid decision-making they
get themselves in quite a misfit of an
adventure exploring the internet and
they explore all the websites you would
not want to explore in a children's
movie man oh my goodness was this an
r-rated film that I was not expecting
yeah the whole scene where Ralph buys a
bunch of guns was just really uncalled
and especially the times were living in
yes we're not cool well you had seen
record Ralph for the first time like the
day before right yeah yeah a couple days
before and I really loved that movie
yeah and I had saw wreck-it Ralph about
a year ago and I really enjoy the hell
out of it I really do like this sequel
though I think it's a lot of fun I'm
gonna try not to compare it to the first
one for most of this review because that
would just be unfair as the the fact of
the matter is they're two very different
films very very different movies a lot
of people when they
see the trailers would often compared to
the emoji movie rightfully so and I've
only seen the trailer should be emoji
movie and I completely got why they were
doing that yeah you've already player
one in there just for ya yeah yeah
definitely
there's a lot of really funny jokes I
laughed a lot I love I gotta say okay I
I definitely cracked up quite a bit one
comparison on makin this is not really a
criticism
the first record Ralph you know it's
like in the video game world the arcade
world you don't really need to be
acquainted with video games to get a lot
of the humor and that's something I
really appreciated about the movie cuz
well there's a lot of jokes that are
very much referential to if you play
games you will get the jokes a lot more
you don't really need to be acquainted
with it it's not gonna affect your
overall enjoyment of the story this
might be a silly statement to make but
if you're not acquainted with social
media and online shopping and a lot of
these things that go on it's is surfing
the web a lot of these jokes ain't gonna
really fly with you you're not gonna get
a lot of it even start dealing with the
algorithms of how websites working all
these things and if that's you and you
happen to be watching this video it's
kind of impressive yeah yeah I mean if
you're gonna go watch Ralph breaks the
Internet odds are you're going it again
most of the jokes alright so I feel like
it's kind of a silly thing to point out
that might be a hindrance
I suppose in terms of the jokey
Department it's so internet-based jokes
but I felt a lot of them really landed I
thought there was some hilarious
commentary in here and I think that this
film is exceptionally more self-aware
than the first one this movie is not
only aware of the internet world to a
very heavy degree but it's also very
much aware it's a Disney film and I
actually liked that I thought the jokes
were really funny like how they tease in
the trailers where they go to the Disney
site or whatever is the Disney corner of
the internet yeah everything Disney owns
lives
I thought they honed in on it extremely
well and they really utilized it don't
want to give away any bits but there
there was one bit in this movie that
garnered a well-earned applause from
vanellope I'm not gonna give it away
but is like yeah I'm gonna clap with
everyone without ya that was a really
well deserved bit right there so I think
it's gonna really stand out so yeah I
really liked it you like it yeah I liked
it I you know it's weird having seen the
first movie just a handful of hours
really before seeing this one and the
main takeaway I got from wreck-it Ralph
- Ralph breaks the internet oh my god he
said that title of the movie the humor
for the most part I mean I'm definitely
a comedy yeah and the biggest difference
for me if you want to compare it to the
first one is just that the first one had
a ton of heart and that's what I left
with and this one I left with more the
fun stuff the cuteness I got the jokes
yeah so if you're gonna be bummed out
that it's more oriented towards the
cuteness and the comedy then that's
something to be aware of but in light of
all that well I don't think it's as good
of a movie as wreck-it Ralph I still had
a great time watching it it's called
Roth breaks the internet and all say is
[Laughter]
it's definitely more vanilla peas movie
this time around whereas in the first
record Ralph Penelope was the B story
who becomes such an integral part is a
major focus of the film it's still
Ralph's movie the first one this one is
Ralph is the supporting character
risking journey
I mean Ralph goes on the journey that is
the more fun one and the one with the
biggest jokes and the one that is the
more relatable part especially in terms
of social media I think the comic relief
in this movie yeah and with that in mind
there was one very because like III
think you hit it on the head especially
with the heart department because it's
not the same who doesn't have heart
because there's no there's plenty of
moments where the heart is really there
and there's a big message in this film
that the trailers do hint at of you know
just because you're best friends doesn't
mean that you should share the same
vision and share the same goals for what
you want in your life I don't agree with
that you need to get your [ __ ] you need
to be exactly like and I will give that
to this movie though that even though I
don't think it has as much of an impact
as the first one
the first film like by the end really
moved me in a way I wasn't expecting
yeah and I do think that the moral of
this one the thing that they're trying
to cut to by the end is actually pretty
sophisticated absolutely oh yeah a
thousand percent also there was one
moment in here that I think if you use
social media at all you'll understand it
but I think especially if you have any
type of experience with backlash off of
saying something to YouTube views and
someone told me hey you know what I
don't want to give away this moment but
it was it was a moment that's
specifically for myself that did get me
to cheer up because I'm like oh man this
scenes for me yeah I definitely click
with that and also you know like because
of the amount of exploration you do in
this movie there's some characters that
you know one very specifically that was
hinted at in the trailers gal gadot
shank it was a racecar driver in it's
something that's very opposite of
Sugarland it's like the heavy metal like
yeah it's like twisted metal whatever
that game is where you're just in cars
wrecking each other all the time
everything is just nasty and cutthroat
and she's not like a funny character but
she's an important character and she's
very much utilized so it's not like one
of those things where they tease a
character in the trailer and then you're
like ah she doesn't walk through and go
hi I'm gal gadot and then she leaves
yeah yeah she's an actual part she's
very much utilized there's a character
alan tudyk players called knows more
which i think had some of the best
laughs like it's such internet joke
heavy but man I loved it I honestly
loved a lot of the jokes in there
there's this money guy character whose
name I can't remember he's in the
trailer on board he's like you want to
make money playing video you wanna get
rich playing video games that guy the
guy who sounds like Bill Hader but for
some reason I can't find his credit
anyway and I forgot his name but he's a
really funny character as well this
movie is a very funny movie and it's
still wildly imaginative with wonderful
animation it might not be as you know
I'm oh Sh '''l II a heavy-hittin in
terms of the the heart department in
terms like spreading it out of letting
it
kind of fluidly get there because I
especially do you think that the third
act kind of goes on a little too long
I'm by the point where characters learn
the lessons and you learn and like I'll
go and hey you know yeah I mean a lot of
this movie to me played out honestly
just in terms of structure like a series
of bits based off the topic being the
Internet and then eventually the
emotional story kind of finds a side
door into the movie and then things
start to wrap up yeah there are a lot of
characters that get sort of checked in
with at the beginning and then kind of
forgotten about until the end well yeah
they're characters more in the arcade
world that you know you might have liked
from the first one or loved from the
first one who you know still make
appearances here that are still funny
yeah but you know they're not focused on
because the story doesn't require it I
don't really know you can make a part
three honestly I don't know how you can
make a part of that you probably just
I'm sure they'll try to milk it or try
to come up with something I mean I'm
sure they could come up with another
lesson but like what is there gonna be
for them to do yeah life according to
maybe video game consoles like that that
was the most I could imagine them doing
are they gonna make like a fix-it Felix
for the modern ad yeah crazy graphics
what exact cuz this movies so big and so
imaginative and meta and self-aware I'm
like I don't really know how much
further you can really go in terms of
the the craziness department I really
did enjoy john c reilly so the livers
vanellope still a great character all
that disney exploration stuff that
seemed like you know the moment of the
chairs that some people were questioned
about i personally thought it was really
funny and really well handled it's
really funny depending on who you are
you might find it just a little sinister
in the sec you're just reminded like wow
disney really does own so for a moment
during some of those more self-aware
sequences I was a little believing it's
just a personal note yeah they're
there's so much really fun really cheeky
stuff especially when Disney rhibs
themselves because they know how to do
it yeah I had a great time and yeah I
highly recommend it if you liked the
first wreck-it Ralph go check this movie
out alright guys we'll have you not seen
it yet not out did you go to a press
screening let me know Ralph Rick's the
Internet what's your favorite website
you
guys can subscribe to the reject nation
click that notification bell hey
download a false on the start us at
people it's well worth it highly
recommend you do it today and yeah don't
forget to spread our videos around on
the dark web that's where we belong yeah